le FMI est une formation unique et des
spécialistes hautement motivés sans égal à l'
abri de toute contre-mesure, mais c'est
une agence du chaos le moment est venu de
dissoudre le FMI maintenant je veux que vous
choisissiez vos prochains mots très soigneusement
où est la chasse la dernière fois que j'ai entendu dire qu'il était
suivre le syndicat
comment se fait-il que la CIA n'ait jamais découvert
d'informations concernant le syndicat auquel vous
voulez jouer une réponse ou la vérité que
nous n'avons jamais rencontrée avant les bons pompiers
Bengie Ethan où êtes-vous Le Syndicat
est une véritable nation voyou formée pour faire
ce que nous faisons  un anti-imf
ils viennent après nous avec tout ce
qu'ils vous ont
préparé cela pourrait très bien être notre dernière
mission faisons en sorte que cela compte alors quel est
le jeu que vous voulez faire tomber le
syndicat c'est impossible
comment savez-vous que nous pouvons faire confiance  ses
moments
désespérés mesures désespérées
bien votre ceinture de sécurité sur vous veut être de
retour maintenant oh hé les garçons qu'est-ce que j'ai raté